this morning Iran's government announced
a number of arrests following a new wave
of suspected poisonings in the country
that appears to be targeting girls
Iranian authorities say more than one
thousand schoolgirls have been sickened
so far the alleged poisonings followed
last Summer's anti-government protests
remain ascencio has more
teenage schoolgirls across Iran laid out
in school Courtyards loaded into
ambulances and laboring to breathe at
hospitals since Saturday a spike in
suspected chemical or biological attacks
that started last November Iranian
officials say more than 1200 girls
across at least 60 schools have been
affected across the country
students describe the smell of something
burning numbness and temporary paralysis
Hamish de Breton Gordon is a British
chemical weapons expert gas particularly
badly made tear gas would create these
sort of symptoms without killing people
and possibly other chemicals like sulfur
dioxide and some people also suggested
nitrogen dioxide
even Iran's supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei weighed in saying if true those
behind this unforgivable crime should be
sentenced to death
but on the streets of Tehran some are
accusing the government of State
terrorism against its own people
possible revenge for the popular wave of
women-led anti-regime protests since
last summer
sparked by the death of Masa amini while
in custody of Iran's morality police for
improperly wearing her head covering I
think you cannot underestimate the
psychological impact of using chemical
and biological weapons any young girl in
Iran thinking about protesting in future
may well think twice if they think
they're going to be potentially gassed
because of that basically it is to
silence protesters and to instill fear
absolutely and those still trying to
protest despite Crackdown so far no
matter the age can suffer for CBS
mornings raymie inocencio London